foreign
what's up Lila
Hi how are you doing we have a party and
how about you
um I'm okay kind of like nervous can't
believe I'm on the show don't be nervous
at all the show's not even that great
what's up
so um I I kind of like had a question um
maybe uh hopefully you can help me
figure it out
can I control my feelings
um I get
um
I feel like down easy like if if I take
someone and don't text me back I like I
start Imagining the wars
um and I start shopping stuff randomly
like whenever I feel like
um not good enough I start buying stuff
randomly it's not extremely like
thousands of dollars but I don't like it
like I buy stuff that I don't need and
then I'm like I shouldn't buy it why did
I buy it and then I started like
um and I making me feel even worse
because like I'm spending money that
there's no need and so I like I start
feeling down and then
I don't know yeah you almost get into
that shame cycle right where you buy
something that you know you don't need
but it makes you feel a little bit
better and then you feel guilty that you
bought it and then you feel ashamed when
it shows up and then you get low and the
only way to make you feel better is that
you think is you go buy something else
and the whole thing starts over again so
it's like a circle and it never gets to
the point to feel good sure and I'm like
I listen a lot to your show and a lot of
shows like um you know to
self-improvement or the minimalists and
stuff like that and I'm like I know I
don't need this
but at the moment I feel like oh this is
what's gonna make me happy I don't know
it doesn't yeah well I'm really really
grateful that you called that means a
lot um let's back out a little bit
I wanna I'm gonna talk more about
feeling low how long have you felt low
it's it's a it's uh it's not all the
time
um and that's another thing that I feel
ashamed of I'm wearing it and my husband
it's amazing he knows all this like I I
can talk to him about this kind of stuff
and he's always there for me
um so hold on hold on hold on hey okay
I need you to hear me say this
it's okay if you if you get down
and it's okay to feel anxious you're not
there's not something wrong with you
you're not broken it doesn't mean you're
a bad wife it doesn't mean you don't
love your husband doesn't mean your
husband's not great
here's the deal it just simply means
your body's trying to get your attention
for some reason
and what we want to do is we want to get
to what's my body trying to tell me
and you hear how there's no shame in
that there's no guilt in that it's just
pure curiosity I wonder I wonder why
that I wonder why that is
and
I would wonder do you have some
girlfriends in your life some women in
your life that you go do things with
that you hang out with or are you are
you lonely no no no I do
tell me about him
um they're great like uh I'm not I'm not
the one though that if I had a problem I
call I usually I just talk to my husband
um but we hang out like often like at
least what different friends like you
know work and outside of work and stuff
like that so you have little ones I'm
sorry you have kids you have little ones
yeah one tell me about them
um she's she's good she's great you know
she's a kid she have a her moment that
the patients it's a little bit push but
she's a great kid she um she had a good
hour
so I remember it was a huge moment for
me when
I started tracking backwards
for me I think I've talked about this on
the show all the time
um I don't have a lot of impulse
shopping sometimes
um
but not usually usually my issue is I go
to junk food I go to go to trash like
unhealthy food
and
it was such a revelation to me when I
realized that almost every time I go
I'm either super exhausted and there's a
lot of real clear literature that
suggests
the more tired you are the more hungry
in the in the poorer the food choices
you make
but almost always there was some sort of
relational issue I was frustrated with
my wife my kids were driving me crazy I
was super annoyed with somebody at work
and I found myself mindlessly grabbing
junk food and I'm sure I could go down a
rabbit hole and figure out the
physiology I didn't really care what the
physiology was I just needed to know
that the trigger had something to do
with when my body felt exposed or lonely
or disconnected from folks
so going along those same lines I would
ask you
the times you can think back to when you
have
felt the need to sit down and impulse
shop to buy something
what usually starts that Domino hits
that first Domino that just rolls the
rest of them down
um if I can like if I like think about
is usually
um either yeah stresser work or I've had
an argument with my husband or with my
kid or I feel like and
I don't know why like I feel like if
if I had a friend then and then I text
you know and if I know everyone's busy
everyone had the life but on my head
it's like if they don't text me what it
is few hours I was like are they mad at
me did I did anything today and I'm like
and I keep going like I don't remember
saying you know doing anything but I'm
like oh but maybe I did and I didn't
realize and then that's when I feel like
the anxiety and then I'm like I just got
online and I started just look around on
things to try to distract my mind and
then I end mine things that I don't need
and I just you know they look good this
look oh I can do this with this yeah oh
of course I mean you man you could talk
yourself into rationalizing any of those
things in the moment right so I want to
back out and give you six six categories
I want you to look at in your life okay
and um you don't have to write these
down because they'll be available when
the show comes out but
um
the six categories I would line out for
you
is the first thing I would sit down and
I would ask you to choose reality to
like really be honest about the reality
of several situations
okay and you for any number of reasons
and I'm sure you and I could talk for a
long long long long time
but you have
in your disposition that you're gonna
make sure everybody sees
a beautiful picture even if things are
really hard behind that picture is that
true
yes yes
I have a feeling that if your husband
was really mean to you one day nobody
would ever ever know
or if you were really really exhausted
and frustrated with your kid no one
would ever ever know
because you have become so gifted over
the course of time probably to to
because you had to
at smiling and saying oh sure it's fine
everything's fine because you don't want
to be a burden to anybody and so I'd ask
you to look at
reality
like what is the state of your marriage
for real what's the state of your
workplace for real what's your state of
your friendships for real being a parent
your relationship with your parents I
want you to look at the landscape of the
relationships in your life that's number
one
and your workplace all that stuff number
two is I want you to begin to choose
freedom to look for places where other
people are deciding what you do
that might be if you owe money to
somebody
that might be in-laws that are making
demands of you that might be a calendar
that is super full and out of control
that might be uh any number of things
that are other people are demanding of
you
and you don't get to drive in the
driver's seat of your own life the third
one is connection we talked about that
earlier about relationships you might be
great on that one awesome the fourth one
is mindfulness and we'll we'll get there
in a second
really mindfulness is simply the gap
between
um
that feeling I want to do this thing
and actually doing it mindfulness is I'm
I'm having this thought but I'm not
gonna go I'm not gonna go through with
it right and then the next one is
belief this idea that you've got to have
something anchored into something bigger
than you are do you have a faith do you
have a faith belief system of any kind
um yeah I mean kind enough I'm not 100
practice but yeah that's okay yeah I'm
not going to prescribe one to you I'm
just gonna say you have to have some
sense that I am not alone in the
universe I'm not I'm not a balloon that
somebody cut the string and I'm just
floating off aimlessly all by myself
because that body is going to always be
anxious because it's going to be
untethered no matter how how good it is
and the last one is you got to choose
health and healing that might be sleep
that might be going to counseling for
the first time in dealing with some
childhood trauma that might be
um any number of I got to deal with this
nagging knee injury or back injury I
just gotta I gotta get well in whole I
gotta quit drinking 45 energy drinks in
the morning before I go to work or
whatever the thing is here's what here's
the picture I want you to have
if your life is a cup
and it's already filled to the brim with
all these things I just talked about
your body's lonely you got a chaotic
schedule you got a bunch of demands all
over on you all the time your
relationships aren't solid you're
untethered you're not well
then when something happens like your
boss hollers at you or somebody cuts you
off in traffic or your husband is snaps
at you
there's no there's no place for that
extra water to go when it gets poured
into the glass and it just spills over
everywhere but if you keep the water in
that glass really low then when life
happens when somebody pours water in it
it's got plenty of space to absorb that
water to to capture that water right and
so
more practically speaking how serious
are you about stopping impulse shopping
how seriously do you just want to quit
100 like every time I bought something I
always like and I look and I I feel it's
got better
um I used to like almost every mom by
shoes clothes these are and now like I
feel like okay it's been months now
but there's days that it's just
I look at it and I said No and then I go
back to the website and then I go back
to the website and I keep like no I
don't need it and then eventually invite
so I would tell you you're gonna have to
do what I had to do several years ago
which is I had to give my debit card to
my wife
I had to take it out of my possession
because I didn't control myself I
couldn't control myself
and mine was always taking people to
lunch oh I got it let's go to lunch
let's go to lunch go to lunch I'll go
get coffee let's go grab dinner
and so it wasn't shoes and shirts as
much as it was I was trying to buy
connection with people because I didn't
think people would want to hang out with
me just to hang out
and so I had to take radical steps I
disconnected Amazon Prime I didn't have
access to it I changed the code I didn't
have access I couldn't get in
and I didn't have my debit card so I
couldn't just go buy things willy-nilly
I had some cash in my wallet and that's
what I used to spend when it was gone it
was gone
but there's some really easy steps you
can take to make it to where I can you
can't just buy stuff
the harder thing will be
being very mindful when you get the
impulse to stop
and pull out a small little binder a
small little notebook that you might get
at like Walgreens or something like that
and just write down what is my body
trying to protect me from what is my
body trying to numb out from
and probably what you're going to find
is you're having problems at work
you're exhausted
your husband is amazing but you could
really use a lot a lot of work at home
with the kids because you're working
full-time too
it can be any number of those things in
those six categories but your body's
trying to just shut the system down
because the glass is full
you can't take you can't take any more
and it just says hey let's do this thing
in the neutral and we're going to head
off this way and just buy some stuff
somebody else might be like be cutting
somebody else might get another drink
and another drink another drink somebody
else might go to pornography somebody
else might go to any number of things
that we're going to do just to numb out
and I'll tell you the same thing I tell
everybody Lila hey thank you so much for
calling
um hang on the line here I'm going to
send you a copy of my brand new book
building a non-anxious life
um we didn't even mean to set it up this
way but it's it's almost just a perfect
handoff for you so I'm going to send you
a copy of the book
um but I tell everybody
you are worth not living a numbed out
life
you are you are created for more than
that you're put here on Earth for more
than just to band it over how you feel
what you wanted what you think what you
need
and just go
you're worth more than that your life is
worth more than that your marriage is
worth more than that your time with your
kids and your friends are worth more
than that your time spent at work is
worth more than that
so Lila I'll ask you I'll ask everybody
listening don't settle for a numbed out
life it's worth the work to head into
the storm and ask your body what are you
trying to protect me from what are you
trying to numb me out from what are you
trying to distract me from
and I gotta head right into the middle
of those storms
because that's where the light is that's
where the healing is
thank you so so much for the call Isla
I'm so I'm so grateful that you call I'm
proud of you for calling
um hang on the line we'll get you hooked
up call anytime anytime everybody
you're worth a peaceful non-anxious life